when can Americans expect their lives to
go back to normal will that not happen
until there's a vaccine I hope very soon
we'll see this is uncharted territory as
you know we think we have ideas it
doesn't help to say what the ideas I
would hope very soon we're we've pulled
together as a nation people are for the
most part doing what they're supposed to
be doing the social distancing is very
interesting a whole new term that's
become a hot it's become somewhat of a
hot term but people are listening and
they're and they're really doing a great
job this country is an amazing country I
think you're up to 141 different
countries right now so it's very
uncharted territory could have could
have been stopped could have been
stopped pretty easily if we had known if
everybody had known about it a number of
months before people started reading
about it excuse me before we started
reading about we could have it could
have been stopped in its tracks
unfortunately they didn't decide to make
it public but the whole world is
suffering because of it the only thing
we weren't prepared for was the the
media the media has not treated it
fairly I'll tell you how prepared I was
I called for a ban from people coming in
from China long before anybody thought
it was in fact it was your network I
believe they called me a racist because
I did that it was many of the people in
the room they called me racist and other
words because I did that because I went
so early so when you say we weren't
prepared had I left these tens of
thousands of people come in from China a
day we would have had something right
now that would have been you wouldn't
have even recognized it compared to
where we are how many people have passed
away how many people have died as of
this moment you could multiply that by a
factor of many many many so when you say
that I wasn't prepared I was the first
one to do the ban now other countries
are following what I did but the media
doesn't acknowledge that they know it's
true they know it's true but they don't
want to write about it yeah